donc à tous je me répète mais maistry
mais n'est-ce pas se répéter
vous avez quatre heures telle est la
question est donc les amibes à écouter
on se retrouve pour une nouvelle arena
francophone ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas regardé une ensemble et on
va se lancer pendant 18 minutes avec ce
tournoi donc je vous laisse vous
installer tranquillement ça permet
toujours de regarder si tu marches
d'avoir voilà vous puissiez commencer et
et on va un petit peu discuté des partis
on va un petit peu rejouer au jeu qu'on
appelait on appelait comment jouer au
jeu de tête un petit peu d éval on va
regarder les parties on va évaluer à
certains moments ce qu'on en pense qu'on
voit et voilà on va sombrer se passer on
va se passer une petite heure et demie
comme ça tranquillement dans la bonne
humeur on a on a le lien du tournoi bien
évidemment on a en a tout ça je vous le
récupérer et et lundi à partir de 17
heures on va pouvoir envoyer du très
lourd avec du maxime vachier lagrave de
partout qui pourra éventuellement gagner
gagner le grand duché ce tour 2010 9 et
j'ai envie de dire bravo
si le gagnant bien sûr je vous raconte
re mind karl scène donc je vais vous
nous envoyez les liens sur sur le tchat
comme d'habitude un jeu laisse un peu de
temps pour arriver il ya grégoire où ce
qui est déjà arrivé je vais essayer lui
mettre le lien sur les deux chat en même
temps tu essaies de faire ce truc très
technique admettre les de liens sur les
deux chat
j'attends vos retours pour pour savoir
si ça a marché
essayez de salut alex killer 74
c'est un petit aréna francophone
tranquille qui mange pas de pain salut à
boom pow wow comme qui le dit holla
holla chico salut funky kiev m
salut tonton
cloud est en train de vous inscrire au
tournoi il reste neuf minutes salut rigo
harry cheikh salue ton ton salut à
fabrice salut à tony la levure
ça y est on sûr qui dit hier sur magnus
vichy et ben écoute merci merci merci ça
m'a appris ça va a pris un certain temps
de la faire mais c'est vrai que la
partie était belle et s'arrêter ça
aurait été dommage de la rate et donc
une belle une belle partie une belle
partie d'un cul comme ça tony ça se sent
ça ça ne se rate pas d'ailleurs elle a
pas mal fonctionné vous ne vous êtes pas
trompés
vous ne vous êtes pas trompé je peux te
dire combien la fée de vue salua sas et
mouthe peut-être ou sarm août
je sais pas comment on commente appelé
tonton je vais fermer la porte de mon
petit studio salut à thomas b2r wayne en
belle partie belle partie belle partie
j'ai envie de dire partie de qualité un
bon soir un vent toxiques
maintenant c'était vraiment une belle
partie la balle est la femis en laye
qu'un presque dix mille vue milles 1600
vue 1100 like
j'ai envie de dire cette partie cette
partie est un athlète quoi cette partie
est un athlète donc dans les prochaines
vidéos qui va y avoir on va avoir
toujours pas cédé partie pédagogique
pour débutants un montage ce week end
et puis après on va partir sur magnus
mvl salua et riku 444 salut à dimitri
18,66 ya quoi soir une petite arena
francophone avec les tontons selon tant
qu'on n'aura pas fait ça changera un
petit peu je vous regardez un peu jouer
on va voir comment comment ça se déroule
on fera un peu un peu de jeu d' analyse
voir qui est mieux qui est moins bien
pour qui pour quoi pour quand on va se
battre on va se mettre tranquille
comment je joins alors je vais remettre
les liens des deux côtés twitch youtube
sur les sur les deux chattes
vous allez pouvoir jouer entre vous il
ya un abo diamants d'un mois à gagner
sur czech comme pour le moment n'est que
de vous inscrire donc ya pas grand monde
mais ça arrive ça arrive souvent dans un
deuxième dans un deuxième temps sur ces
tournois et va essayer de suivre un
maximum de partis et je vois ce jeu de
l'évaluation pour voir un peu qu'ils
aient mieux pourquoi comment j'ai envie
de dire j'ai envie de dire ça comme ça
c'est quoi l'idée pour les deux chabat
en fait c'est juste que maintenant son
stream
enfin chess comme un pas moi sur ma
chaîne perso moi je reste quand même à
foule twitch match comme stream est sûre
et sur czech com et sur youtube
en même temps on écoute et enfin parce
qu'ils veulent un j'ai envie de dire
c'est leur life salut à yasmine
ouais ouais il décide de faire les deux
mais ça lui allait au delà champlain en
un mois sur sur ma chaîne perso je fais
que du fait que du switch à titre
personnel je trouve que c'est mieux
enfin en tout cas pour ma chaîne à moi
mais pour eux pourquoi papa préfère
peut-être faire switcher youtube et
pourquoi pas failli font ce qu'ils
veulent en fait c'est seller life un
gîte chacun fait sa life un salut à
zombie moi ma foi pour moi ça change
rien quoi salut à adrien bonsoir poisson
bull
bonsoir l'élite bonsoir poisson builder
faut vérifier que ce soit bien bien
partis quand même sur chess comme au
passage à mein führer par 90 on tond je
te remets les liens et par ivor tarte et
à l'heure tu peux tu pas n'être plus à
l'heure que ça ça commence dans deux
minutes de toute façon c'est une arène
donc même si c'est en retard jean vitus
râleur il ya ça n'attaque
sanaa trajet ce qui hélas à lui à dealer
de string salut à une godbert ilias à la
trappe chess mal avec l'addiction
aujourd'hui sa natte ratchet j'ai vu
vlad aussi tu as ta maaf ça ne va plus
quoi tu vois vlad et tu ne sait plus
parler on voit vlad et on se sent joueur
d'échecs et on se sent grand maître bref
j'ai mangé au fast food asiatique je
vous dis tout de suite
histoire de bien tu as de bien montrer à
tout le monde un peu level qui a ce soir
donc là tu vois j'ai fait des petits
rouleaux de printemps un petit riz
poulet curry j'ai envie de te dire bon
est ce que cet homme est battable et
salue sa matraque et quand même j'ai
envie de dire membres diamants non
membres platini les platines il est non
il est premium mais je crois que ses
platines il est membre platini la la
couronne il ya beaucoup de platine
il ya des platines de partout ce soir je
ne peux pas le voir à l'écran mais je
suis en train de voir quatre membres
pyatt platine un membre de diamants et
des membres or mais le platine a la cote
le platine a la cote est normalement
normalement normalement les mecs je
flippe un peu de vous dire ça mais
normalement lundi
les leçons sortant français je flippe
qui a encore déçu retard mais là on est
on est proche de chez proche de ses
proches
je vous tiendrai au courant lundi mais
là on approche dangereusement quoi enfin
pas dangereusement parce qu on est super
heureux que ça sorte
mais on approche et je ne veux plus
traduire une seule de son avis les mecs
je vous dis tout de suite je ne
traduirai plus le son de ma vie vous
allez voir m kiev en train de traduire
des leçons tu vas être heureux tu verras
tu vas tu va poser ta voix sur 125 leçon
tu vas être heureux maintenant qu'on
s'est un peu comment il gagne son argent
clearstream
tu vas être heureux
salut car le bouquet salua salue ton ton
salut le charpentier mais donc faut
aller vous pourrez entendre ma voix j'ai
envie de te dire suave alexandre
actuarielles et partis concurrents
directs et les commenter ouais c'est un
peu le délire alex raphaël qui salue ton
qu'on s'est toujours plaisir de
t'entendre et te voir écraser les petits
slips écoute ce soir les petits slips
peuvent dormir tranquilles les slips
force jaune devant marron derrière vont
pouvoir vont pouvoir passer un bon
moment je ferme la porte
ça démarre dans vingt secondes et moi on
peut se regarder aller
allez les mecs ça démarre dans cinq
secondes et on est là salut à tous je
dis bonjour à léo allez on va se régaler
partie on va d'abord regarder les
joueurs
j'ai envie de dire à fortiori leader du
tournoi donc là joseph michel avec les
pièces blanches contre panthère à
fatalis de 4,5 qui relève trois
cavaliers investissent donc une petite
petrov c'est pas une mauvaise couverture
ça peut jouer la d3 ou un adversaire
avec les blancs qui veut pas rentrer
dans la lande cavaliers 5 fait des trois
qu'un coup un peu mou puisqu'on vend
dans un an dans une écossaise avec comme
certains tentent plus cédé 3 enfin une
écossaise quatre cavaliers donc la
pantera fataliste qui a fait des cinq et
il est même content parce que
normalement si on regarde ce truc à la
couleur opposée y aurait le fou qui
arrivera en b 5 ce qui pourra pas être
le cas là il fait fou j'ai 5 des cas de
fermeture du centre attention ce coût
des quatre toujours toujours se méfier
car il y ait des 5 fu hausse est
probablement
alors que vaut cette position avec cette
fermeture du centre les blancs ils vont
essayer de jouer quoi ils peuvent plus
étroits à tout moment pour ouvrir
est-ce que genre cavalli prend cet essai
3 ça peut être une option de gagner la
paire de fou comme ça ce genre sur
cavaliers prendre ceinturé quoi dame
prendre cette non il prend un fils prend
m6 mais quel est l'intérêt de prendre f6
de toute façon il faut aussi son match
assez cavalier on fera dame prend m6
j'aurais préféré du coup si on avait
cette philosophie prendre cette sphère
c3 est sûre h6 pourchassé faire
foudroyer fils dame preuve six en ayant
gagné un tempo 2 h 6 quoi en gros là le
truc c'est que tu fais prises avec 6
prises hafsi c'est quand le mec va faire
fou aussi tu vas faire cavalier prend
bon il joue avec ses 4 mais disons que
d'une manière x ou y
bah voila tu vas être obligé de prendre
un f6 donc c'était peut-être plus malin
de prendre 7 et de se laisser chassés de
faire faux problème 6 au moment convenu
donc maintenant on a cette structure de
pions avec un éventuellement d'un
éventuel des cats qui va arriver
maintenant
j'ai envie de dire probablement le fou
qui va venir angers 4 la tour en des
huit j'aime bien les noirs qui du coup
vont pouvoir jouer sur un pion qui va
avoir du mal à avancer en d4
je pense fou g4 un coût important ici
s'il n'y a pas de tactique ou quoi je
fais ça à mains nues un c'est de
l'analyse a maintenu un mea fou g4
retour des 8es vie c'est le pion des ce
serait vraiment on observe options de
jeu numéro un ce serait vraiment une
option de jeu numéro un c'est pas vous
commencez ffu aussi ce truc c'est que
cette carte des 4 est vraiment
importante parce que le fou aussi c'est
vraiment important et je sais pas je ne
sais pas et du coup avec les blancs le
coup que je regarderai s'était arrêté
des quatre direct est ce que est ce que
vous comprenez que des cats soit
vraiment un coup critique ici dans le
chat joue laisse me répondras j'ai envie
de dire j'ai envie de dire je vous pose
une question mischer de qui dit non non
mais le truc c'est que tu menaces des 5
es tu places tong sang entre après faut
que ça marche et c'est vous comprenez
rien quoi s'amuser ça abusé les mecs ce
que fout au 6e tour à des 8 tu vas avoir
du mal à jouer à jouer des quatre
maintenant et tu vas te faire vis à vis
et donc c'était vraiment la question est
ce qu'on pouvait jouer des quatre direct
non mais ce que vous comprenez les mecs
que parfois des chèques un temps c'est
vraiment une grosse différence
ah on est trop mauvais mais on a été
trop intelligent là dessus voilà il
réussit à faire des quatre qu'on aime
finalement et je pense c'est vraiment un
truc important dans cette position
s'était tout l'idée de fou g4 en fait
c'était vraiment je remonte parce que
bon c'est un peu primordial j'ai envie
de dire je vous fais un peu hachée mais
fou g4 c'était vraiment primordial c'est
je m'en prends en aux cavaliers
s'étaient pourquoi c'était pour m'en
prendre à la casse des quatre pour
arriérés le pion détroit ouais j'ai
envie de te dire tu as ya de la logique
tu vois c'est une pensée qui suit un fil
non mais c'est on a une pensée trop
complexes les mecs on a une pensée trop
complexe non mais vraiment vous nos facs
et logique pour vous pas non mais
vraiment en faites vous
room trop les normes et soyons sérieux
deux minutes d'ailleurs il a mis le feu
aux anges et 4,1 finalement mais a
surtout pris 3 il ya cinq intermédiaires
et ouais et william intermédiaires et il
ya ces sept qui peut être loyer mais aux
cinq têtes d'un match 4 3 3 des 4 pts
est juste ou f3 tour des quatre et il ya
ces sept en l'air non mais bon mais y'a
personne qui me répond en plus un salut
françois jacq à vous êtes vous êtes
incorrigible sur le chat vous êtes
incorrigible et mec non mais j'essaye
vraiment de vous expliquer des trucs
enfin à je me fais troll directes at il
répondu dans l'âme et je me fais 3 le
direct bon écoutez bravo hein
brahim et la pression sur ses six à lui
avoir dit non le chat salut tonton donc
il articule était d'accord ces cinq axes
qui va prendre maintenant à récupérer e5
alors cette position vous préférez les
blancs et les noirs ou personne
d'ailleurs la c6 jouer et on voit la
domination du fou sur le cavalier
avantage blanc en est ce que ça vous
rappelle un thème là ce fut un f3 escaré
y en a cinq
est ce que ça vous rappelle un thème
dans le chat se fout compte ce qui a
valu au bord puisque ça nous rappelle
une partie ouest am very rich ou que
dans les parties récente et à peut-être
un peu dans l'esprit
steinman of chaos jm2l mais voilà tout à
fait tout à fait tout à fait vous avez
l'eref les mecs c'est bien on va essayer
de passer des raids 18-25 coreff au
greffe échec est là maintenant ils
menacent fois ci ce qui est bien joué le
cavalier complètement inutile il va la
gagner juste juste un cadre déjà air est
un coup ici à 4 semble être un coup mais
j'imagine qu'à plein de plein de
manières différentes de traiter à 4 à 6
il va essayer de tenir tu échanges et
essayer de gagner ce pion salut de ce
type se débrouiller je n'ai pas donné
tous les coups c'est à joseph michel il
est où jacky du coup joseph michel il
est où jacky l'année 3 très bien joué de
la part la part de joseph puisque
surtout repenser cette île vous sur la
petite tactique tour des huit ont pensé
cet efficace efficace donc faut
peut-être faire cavalier paix cette dame
dès cette année y'a pas et cavaliers des
six meilleurs atours au t1 d'impro de
bryce tu veux lutter de façon qui est
bcp et des 6 1 mais tu apprends b5 du
coup éventuellement à mettons qu'on
sessad à ce moment là s'il veut tenter
quelque chose souffert carolyn bessette
ou cavaliers c'est qu'elle sait qu à
kadam
8 que cavaler bessette qui permet de
tenir
dams est alors attendez 2007 c'était une
idée aussi dame prend p5 aller sur tours
c'est cette attend ça va peut-être damas
cinq à tour c1 et surtout reprend il ya
dame prend à m haies dames b8 bien joué
bien jouer joseph et michel qui a été
propre et pantera fatalis qui a qui a
craqué à l'on va continuer à avoir des
joueurs qui ont des lots similaire saaq
province et comment il ya eu cavale des
quartiers ces sites une écossaise à mach
4 qui consiste d'un point 4 me de prises
prise ddc donc ithaque 21 faudra me
revoir les vidéos sur les là l'écossaise
d'un match 4 alors juste un petit rappel
l'idée qu'on avait eu mes mots
techniques c'est qu'on protégé par
cavalli ces trois pions fou b4 et quand
il y avait cloué retrouve plus le
défendre on finissait par faire flouer 2
et assure d'un prend le cas de mémoire
ces cavaliers b5 le coup je me rappelle
même pas moi même tu vois mais j'ai
envie de te dire revoir la vidéo moi
aussi du coup mais dans l'esprit c'était
ça mais là du tout va il a pas revu la
vidéo et et il se retrouve avec un pion
ou moins nettes alors on va voir comment
les noirs vont vont essayer de le
convertir web internet et dans le mal
bike et bessat espère y aussi un vomi
sur tout perdre et un de façon donc avec
les blancs on essaye de faire une
expansion à six auxquelles j'ai bien ce
qu'il fait avec les blancs ils essayent
de prendre de l'espace mais avec les
noirs faut pas oublier un plan qui je
pense à une partie de bronstein comme ça
tours 8 fou j'ai huit cavaliers bouger
f6 pour remettre le fou en jeu sur cette
diagonale là c'est un plan qui pour
employer plus tard ya aussi des plans et
jesse st pour casser la structure avère
adverse mais le plan avec fougue et 8
tf6
ça peut être un plan important est ce
que vous l'aviez dans le chat le plan
fouchet 8 à 6 est ce que le chat aller
le plan ou pas on va voir ce que le chat
à le plan rouge et 8 tf6 boxeur qui dit
non mais j'suis pas toujours si troy
bodie cher ou pas france / l'équipe ah
oui quoi d'autre voilà donc françois
jacquier bien mais tu as et les vieilles
les vieux classiques après tu peux jouer
avec g61 pour pour échanger et faire g5
mais c'est assez utile de connaître le
fou g8 f6 aussi fait-il c'est pas un
plan sa reprise j'ai embrassé un plan
quand même j'ai envie de dire mais c'est
un petit plan important à connaître
donc ça échange d'accords ont là pour
prendre du non non il donne le pion des
mais bordel j'ai le droit fallait fans
depuis longtemps de façon
enfin après il est pas trop de temps
mais l'algérie 6 on a senti que c'est un
pas un coup bien inspiré on a vu qu'on
avait du temps elle aurait pu juste
faire un petit roi c'est cette se
consolider et préparer le fou j'ai huit
cavaliers h7 f6 éventuellement ou jouer
g6 quand même mais le petit roy c7 quand
même pour soutenir son pion faible
c'était pas trop demander un bon bah
écoute et une partie qui tourne bêtement
en fait une erreur j'ai envie de dire
une erreur embêtante du joueur noir mais
qui est pas forcément encore si mal donc
il y avait cinq sous pression pour le
moment et il peut vouloir faire droit à
ces sept cavaliers ou 5 disons disons
bon ça reste une position intéressante
parce que peut-être que visuellement
vous pensez que les blancs sont mieux
mais ces visuels en fait les pièces
blanches par alix ou demande dans le
chat si en effet fou g8 et si ça va se
voir il va contrer oui mais en fait
admet je fais tour 8 toi je te fait roi
c7
en fait tu vas contrer ça comme enfin je
vais bouger mon fou je vais enlever mon
cavalier je vais faire f6 fait avec les
blancs si je fais ça tu feras tu as tu
fait un peu la gueule quand même pas
qu'est ce que tu vas me faire en fait ça
le truc c'est que je n'ai pas de
faiblesse avec les noirs il n'y a pas
grand chose à faire je ferai peut-être
des cinq au passage et après je mettrai
le fou un f 7 et je couvre bien quoi
mais je peux comprendre que ce ne soit
pas toujours simple de réussir à sentir
quand est ce qu'on a le temps de faire
les plans n'ont pas pas croire c'est
vraiment important de faire roi c7 et
cavaliers ou 5 kg 5
mais tu peux pas faire g5 direct parce
qu'à tours h6 pour s'accroissent et 7
c'est important en plus c'est un petit
truc mémo technique
alors là les mecs de nouveau c'est quand
un car ayant ces trois comme ça c'est
pas mal d'avoir le roi ans et sept ont
fait une focale et le roi il peut pas
être attaqué ni par un fou de cases
noires ni par un cavalier
donc il va être bien en sécurité autour
des 4 et maintenant qu'il ya eu 5
on touche le fou ou g5 peut-être parce
que passion avouée 4 alors est ce que
fut le cas très pénible peut-être
peut-être commencer par g5 direct c'est
pas idiot pour venir un peu le fixer sur
blanc bonne façon il a fait flasher un
nom sur mon g5 quand même pour eux
pour activer le fou qua non oui tour f8
qui a lieu quatre bien joué j'ai cinq là
quand même tu peux tu peux pas laisser
ce fou dormir on croirait un réflexe on
croire à un lien leur complexe de niveau
1 les mecs non mais vraiment je commence
à payer à part les pokémon quand je vois
quand je vois un fou comme ça voilà g5
bien joué et dans les petites idées
sympas wiper cavaliers f3 et s'il prend
tout reprend et on va on va chasser le
curage 3 tel un demi de mêlée talent un
demi de mêlée quoi ni touré fins a gagné
tour est fait un fou j'ai 2 way touré
fins à gagner rai3 france a gagné la
pièce
quoique vais peut-être qu'à rédiger
trois années tour j'ai un regret
peut-être à gagner peut-être il a raté
tour f1 mais s'il a raté tout récent ça
a marché maintenant aussi d'autant plus
puisqu'il ya ça sous pression à mais
peut-être maintenant que sur kg 3 tours
janvier à tours à 3 rebonds peu importe
mais essaye de voir les plans les idées
c'est l'idée c'est pas forcément de voir
que les tactiques
si j'ai réussi à les voir vous les 10
mai faut avoir des plans for de
l'imagination dans vos parties et tonton
c'est vraiment important d'être
imaginatif
alors là attention il entrain peut-être
de se mettre dans le cac ait laissé un
cavalier aussi se passer non rivas le
prendra les tours d un actif toi et
attaque ses deux jouent sur ton fois
cette c1 foot scandinave ça mais moi il
va te faire flouer quatre fous g8 fond
de court là c'est rafael nadal les mecs
là le mec vient de gagner la coupe davis
est bien placé le roi plante qui est en
diagonale par rapport aux cavaliers ça
peut être utile c'est-à-dire qu'il ya
pas de n'y a pas d'échec imminent au et
l'a 26 secondes
ithaque 21 hors tac 21 il va il va voir
flou les amis il va voir flou ithaque 21
il a plus le temps il a plu le tan même
j'ai envie de dire le times ne tient
plus cotés côté blanc même celle du
cavalier aussi ce qui traîne avec
peut-être un pion f6 enfin deux
variantes
mémé ya plus de temps allez vous prend
au système paula faut se dépêcher un
côté côté français côté côté diamant à
le diamant le diamant qui va peut-être
parler qui va briller de tous et kara de
toutes ses facettes
un diamant qui a de la ressource allez
peut-être cavalli f4 est allé jouer pour
du cac radio deux échecs et pour jouer
le match
non là il tac qui wake garde mais là il
y avait des f4 qui arrive
c'était bien joué tour des six le
cavalier qui est bien et voilà
maintenant il ya cavalli pour un f3
bêtement et ça va rebondir vers f2 et
ithaque qui va qui va s'incliner
shame shame
et bah écoutez c'est dommage
allez on va jouer on va regarder une
autre partie on va regarder dans ce qui
vient de de commencer allez on va avoir
peut-être le beau gosse le beau gosse
mexicain alors comment il a fait la
fessée 4c 6g trois des cinq c'est bien
avec les noirs il prend le centre il
développe le fou aulas peut-être pu se
mettre plus sur f5
ça évite de se prendre un caillou 5 ou
quoi et là y'a peut-être h3 mais bon il
frappe wave c'est un qui ment a laissé
bien il va y aller à la dérive à faire
foi je crois directement écoutez c'est
pas mal parce qu'au moins il a une idée
écoutez moi j'ai toujours un jour à 1200
qui a une idée comme ça qui veut faire
quelque chose c'est déjà un bon premier
pas il propose des changes des fouilles
pourra faire [ __ ] prendre cavalli avec
6,6 ou des six rock
ma foi ça va chapiteau qui je vous
rejoins voilà du coup tu prend 1,5 tu
prends tu prends g2 et tu fais six
cavaliers 7/4 et lycées 6 voilà ça par
exemple cela peut être une bonne idée et
on va ramener ses cavaliers versé 6 qui
a une belle case à apprendre et on verra
ce qu'on fait du x fuite d'un me si ça
aide à mieux si c'est dommage
et oui parce que maintenant il va se
prendre damas quatre il va se faire
presser en c6 il pouvait le prendre ce
cavalier s'était pas tabou il s'était
pas tabou maintenance adam va devoir
courir en retrait il va y avoir du damas
cats qui va arriver
il le prend maintenant mais du coup il a
perdu dame si vous voyez il a perdu un
temps il a perdu un temps hélas fait
d'armes si souvent h3 damage 3 alors que
s'il avait pris lui même
l'autre est sûrement pris en chasse
trois dames 3 3 il aurait la même
position mais j'aurai deux coups il
aurait pu jouer d'amd 7,6 soit aussi ce
direct parce que la caisse qui se prend
les mecs très haut blanc qu'est-ce que
vous jouez très roulant il a joué le
coup damas quatre là le classique il ya
plus personne qui peut revenir sur la
diagonale toutes les pièces ont disparu
il se prend dames 1 4l clasico el fahm
au zoo et là il est raide mais je pense
que wade a même si ça lui coûte cher
mais ça est ce que c'est un thème que
vous connaissez le thème du petit échec
là qui vient qui vient faire mal
est ce que vous connaissez dans le tchat
ouais c'est dommage
assez dur de lutter et là c'est dur le
roi est démuni et même sur wade 8 amène
dans les coups un peu marrant fouet 3 tu
as qui menace ou v6 échec parce que tu
es cloud et tu as eu quatre pour ouvrir
pas donc eu qu'à ta phu étroite à mes
fautes 3 amiens mais logique
logique bon il va essayer de venir à
mais là vous prend à cet effort parce
que sur cavaliers ses 6 x 6 contre échec
ouais non c'est dur franchement j'aurais
tenté jo la magouille
j'aurais tenté cavaliers h6 fou à cet
écart est léger 4 mais j'aurais espéré
mais ça marche mais ne pas y avoir foule
v6 3 7 pouces et 5 3 des 8 est prise
mais au moins je le tente un matelas
battu pas parce que maintenant ils
chialent 1
dommage un dommage mon petit déception
pour réveiller mexicain qui avait bien
mené sa barque et donc pour en revenir
sur le début de partie il avait joué
avec un plan il avait une conviction
c'était pas mal c'était d'aller changer
ce point je crois pourquoi pas mais sur
ce qui a valu aux saintes juste bêtement
tu prends et bien vous faites quoi
surtout courageux 3 annonce ça marche
pas il est peut-être qu'à relief trois
échecs intermedia qu'il faut être
intéressant mais juste tu prends il
prend et tu reviens et après aussi ce
qu'avait lieu 7 kgs c6 et perd le chat
ta joue tu vois enfin après c'est pas
c'est pas la fin du monde pour les
blancs mais voilà enfin tu peux jouer
comme ça il va sûrement faire 4 voilà -
il est dans la partie quand il joue à
les parties suivantes à on tombe sur un
début de partie de bluepoint which qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis un petit moment à
the blueprint which on voit plus sur les
lives on voit plus sur twitch on le voit
plus bleu tu as i lay blood and honey
d'adast et miss élues le bluepod switch
on voyait un peu et tout on a eu des
échos puis on voit plus du tout alors ça
ça va être dur pour les noirs fallait
peut-être joué plus solide et peut-être
jouer aussi ce dont je le fous des six
rapide le truc dans les systèmes de
londres bon ça peut être joué à mesdames
b3 là c'est un peu pénible dame b si
c'est ça moi non mais ça joue ça vous en
faites
s'ajoutent dame prend b3 et qui a aidé
sept sages ou même celui que j'aime pas
trop
il va y avoir tour c'est un et il va se
faire presser sur la colonne c'est là il
va reprendre 2e et tour c1 et le
placement de saddam est un peu mal c'est
une dame ameur a il a une dame hammer il
a une dame hammer ouais c'est lundi
maxime magnus vous pourrez suivre en
notre compagnie
annoncé et salua maboul ma roue et salua
20e but 50e strict banques berlin brême
alors là ton pseudo mec sérieux c'est un
problème quoi ça lui arrive trop bas y'a
un pseudo dans le chat est à ma mère ou
je fais un malheur
thual adama meurs tu as 30 des caraïbes
et 5 va prendre des trucs pénible à la
longue de quelques savaient pas qu'ils
inscrivent aujourd'hui même et c'est
l'ironie du sort ouais quand on en
parlait tout à l'heure j'ai fait des
demandes et où on devrait avoir un psd
qui arrive dans alors il ya cinq
skilling aux états unis mais qui devrait
arriver à quatre là ça peut être des
coups intéressants tu vois les mecs
parce que il n'ya pas à 5 ski adam prend
b6 et à 4 tu veux faire à 5 pour prendre
de l'espace et et dire aux cavaliers tu
vas ou frère gérard tu lui dis tu vas ou
frère non sérieux tu retournes en 17
mais moi j'ai gagné mon pion à 5 en gros
tu as perdu de temps j'ai perdu de temps
mais moi j'ai fait des trucs à 4 à 5 ça
c'est un coup on l'a dans le chat ou pas
est ce qu'on a à 4 à 5 dans le chatt
bamanans sur la carte à 5 y aura
peut-être y aura peut-être carélie c4
parce que tu as leur en fait un truc qui
se passait c'est que sur à quatre fous
aussi c'est peut-être on se dit qu'à mes
yeux 5 tu vois je sais pas quand je
monte des idées après il ya cavaliers 17
ici et ça joue c'est peut-être
intéressant mais cavaliers des trois
cavaliers ou cinq maintenant maintenant
cavalier l'aubois debout h4 qui va
devoir revenir par là l'article sur les
échecs de cramique son rock
ces liquides comme article ces liquides
c'est nul en fait on veut faire les
échecs sans roque
on va continuer avec les parties de six
heures que personne ne veut regarder
mais au moins on ne craque pas un
voilà ce qui va se passer si on fait les
échecs sans roque je vous le dire tout
de suite c'est que la théorie dans trois
quatre ans elle va être plus ou moins la
même qu'aujourd'hui
bon j'exagère un peu mais ça va être
pareil et les gens ils regardent pas les
échecs pourquoi parce qu'il ya trop de
nuls ou parce que ça dure trop longtemps
1 est ce que la critique des gens quand
il détourna d'échec c'est
ouais il ya trop de nuls ou est-ce que
ces web au parti elle dure six heures
les mecs on n'a pas le temps on taffe ya
aucun aucun événement sportif ou quoi ou
10 sport qui dure six heures la game et
c'est un peu ça le problème
donc j'ai envie de te dire et en plus il
te dit c'est kramnik qu'il est là en
mode où il ya autant nul que l'on fasse
rock ou pas tu vois mais c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça le problème des échecs
institué le problème des échecs
aujourd'hui en 2010 9,1 bientôt 2020
c'est de savoir si on peut re ok ou pas
hein c'est à dire que la voilà c'est
écrit dans l'article de cramique voilà
c'est vérifiable
c'est ça le problème des échecs en 2020
c'est la légende ne regarde pas parce
qu'il ya trop de nuls ben non en fait
bah logique quoi
non on a en fait en fait les gens
regardent pas ce que je te regarde pas
parce que c'est trop long cramique en
parle pas moi j'en parle voilà point
barre c'est pas tabou j'ai raison j'ai
pas raison les mais quand vous dites le
aussi j'ai pas raison enfin tu vois
enfin pendant pour ce que veut chacun
son avis là peut-être je peux faire fou
aux 5 avec l'idée sur m6 vous prend
enfin tu peux prendre 4 parce que tu as
attaque fouet le truc tu aurais pu faire
cailler prendre 4 comprend qu'il est
prend 1,5 sur puis on prend à tapas
krepski adams et 8 ha ouais mais tu vois
il a pas les chasser avec carel et b5 et
il se fait prendre le criait ça dure
soit un musée marc wilb personnes au
regard de cricket à part à part ce
videur et j'ai envie de dire c'est un
sport mineur jeu là faut arrêter avec le
cri quatre personnes au regard du
cricket il ya quatre anglo saxons qui se
tiennent la main qui regardent du
cricket ça va bungert au bout d'un
moment tu vois c'est l'exception qui
confirme la règle et en plus le cricket
c'est sans perte de vitesse le cricket
j'ai vu jimmy gmi jiminy cricket il m'a
dit il m'a dit sérieux dans ma ville
cricket sérieuse c'est fini
ce qui est bien en plus avec les échecs
rapide parce que ça faut le savoir aussi
c'est qu'il ya moins deux nuls aussi
avec elle prend des cinq au nom mais nan
mais the do bonne bim bim bim tu fait
tout péter tonton tu fait tout péter
faut prendre un brand tranquille teklu
et on joue sur la dame on joue sur la
dame on en parle depuis le début de
cette dame assez dommage ça quand même
c'est dommage ça c'est dommage il a pas
et voilà et maintenant il rappelé au cad
bon maintenant il faut que tu fasses ah
nan mais peut-être des prend à eux mêmes
et joue avec mes parents et ses quatre
peut-être tu as fait pour entourer de
tourbe et un c4
bon après tout reprend jouable aussi non
mais les mecs
en fait ils font des carrières de
joueurs d'échecs qui sont contre le
changement de toute leur vie à un moment
donné ils arrivent en mode faut tout
changer il invente une règle à une règle
ok on va pur ok ok on va pur ok mais
palmarès de pure hockey non mais sérieux
et en plus ils changeraient qui existait
déjà mais en plus il a eu accès à alpha
0 pour tester son truc palmarès d'aaland
tu vois aussi en terme de consommation
d'électricité il a bouffé d'électricité
1 pour tester son truc d'échec l'impact
carbone da nantes pour son idée est que
plus on va pouvoir prendre l'avion les
amis on va pouvoir prendre l'avion
vous m'avez compris vous m'avez compris
on va pouvoir faire des allers retours
tu vas pouvoir pouvoir faire des tours
du monde on va pouvoir faire des tours
du monde parce que là l'impact carbone
d'utiliser alpha 0 pour garder ce que ça
donne les échecs sans rockets personne
n'en parle moi j'en parle donc non ça au
nom pas dame prend des 5
non tu te retrouves avec un pion isolé
des catins tu vas te prendre tour des
huit foot ont regardé le contour des
huit tours 17 fou des huîtres ou b si
c'est le pion des quatre îles vanille va
sauter les mecs il va sauter pourquoi
échanger les dames d'altran bessette
tonton d'intrants b cette attaque le
foot attaque tout mais là là là là là il
arrive à pêcher la manne en pions isolé
final le fou de la bonne couleur c'est
fini ah il est mort bluepoint which il
est mort il est mort les amis il est
mort il est mort the blueprint witch
voilà là il va prendre fou des huits
tranquille
voilà wife cette fouille b6 c'est un
festival de gladiator c'est un festival
les amis non mais sérieux pour revenir
ce truc de cramé du coup vous en pensez
quoi est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un
consensus dans le chat est ce qui peut
avoir un straw poll un truc tu vas
jean-monnet ont fait la révolution des
échecs ici ou pas il y avait peut-être
du fouquet cas tout à l'heure sur toi on
va exact voyez-vous et 4
tu vois on a tous ratés sitruk thermique
passé serait que bloom est inquiète pas
oui durable a dit ça va ça va jamais
passe un truc de cramé qu'en fait tu
m'aimais bouger pourquoi changer les
cadences c'est tabou en fait pourquoi
faire le truc que tout le monde aimerait
c'est tabou ça j'arrive pas à comprendre
les mecs j'arrive pas à comprendre on
veut tous que les cadences soit plus
rapide tu parles avec le public tu quand
échanges un peu avec les fans des échecs
les gens qui regardent des échecs qui
consomment des échecs quand un peu cet
échange avec les gens tu vois quand tu
t'intéresses aux gens en fait tu te
rends compte que le problème c'est la
cadence vraiment tu t'en rends compte
pourquoi ne pas vouloir faire plaisir à
ton tube
genre tu un public tu as des gens qui te
paye qui kiffent pour regarder ce que tu
fais pourquoi à un moment tu penses pas
à eux
moi c'est ça la question fondamentale
que je me pose pourquoi un moment donné
tu ne penses pas aux gens qui regardent
les déchets qui consomment des échecs
qui échangent des échecs avec toi qui
kiffe les échecs en fait pourquoi n'y a
pas un moment où on se dit bah on va
alors je mette la partie de grave à tort
on va faire un truc qui fait plaisir aux
fans se fait plaisir aux gens quoi
c'est ça la question qui me parlent les
échecs par correspondance ça existe
encore monsieur p soit c'est un jeu très
intéressant
lord il n'a pas du tout eu eder marensin
gratuit on fait on tue le l'esprit du
sport faire du plaisir au public mais
c'est pas du tout ça avec ross dos c'est
quand même tu fais plaisir à tout le
monde je fais plaisir aux joueurs aussi
tu pas à l'esprit quand tu avais quand
tu quand tu
fait des cadences plus rapide 1 enfin
c'est une change pas les règles du jeu
tu gardes le même truc est au contraire
tu gagnes qu'ils gardent l'esprit des
échecs un peu bistrot les échecs un peu
finalement qui se joue et qui sont
toujours joué en fait qu'il soit un peu
dans les bars à l'époque à la régence de
partout tata toujours eu cet esprit de
faire des parties simplement maintenant
on est devenu tellement fort que avant
pour produire un contenu de qualité
il nous fallait des heures parce que les
joueurs étaient pas assez fort mais
aujourd'hui avec le niveau de
connaissances qu'on a un magnus carlsen
en 3 + 2 est plus fort qu'un paul murphy
avec six heures à la pendule cas ce que
je veux dire c'est ça le truc c'est ça
le truc c'est que le le niveau de jeu
des gens si tu veux être venu est devenu
impressionnant est devenu impressionnant
on n'a plus besoin si tu veux de
d'autant de temps qu'avant c'est simple
on te dit quand tu joues en semi rapide
quand tu joues en semi rapide en gros
quand que les joueurs ont 20 ou 25
minutes puisque dix secondes au lieu de
partie longue classique donc en en 2h40
quand on dit qu'il faut enlever
[Musique]
100 points elo ont 10 ans points elo on
dit qu'un 2800 joue à 2700 en gros si tu
passes de rapides à 2,25 +10 apa cadence
longue
donc ça veut dire qu'un magnus carlsen
donc ce type est un athlète c'est un
athlète s'est refait magnus carlsen est
sortie elle a encore des parties d'un
niveau supérieur à 27 50
je pense que c'est suffisant si tu veux
vraiment du haut niveau tu regardes les
parties d'alpha 0 contre alpha 0 tu as
envie de te dire tu t'en fait pas ou tu
fais ou tu fais de l'échec par
correspondance mais un niveau tu vois
des parties une partie au dingli rennes
carlson tu vois c'est c'est de 27 contre
27,50 tu vois ça reste très qualitatif
si tu veux faut ça reste très qualitatif
c'est un peu écarté de la reina mais bon
on aime bien parler aussi pourquoi les
ordis n'ont pas tué les achète par
correspondance quelle différence
en fait le truc des chèques par
correspondance aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
ya ben il ya je pense qu'il ya 90 % nul
1-1 ou 95% nul mais le truc c'est que si
tu joues avec un situer de l'ordi en
fait sommes plus humain badia certaines
parties que tu vas réussir à gagner et
ça et ça tu prends ses partenaires ces
choses là je pensais que ce serait tabou
n'est ce pas de tabou ce pas tabou
l'homme peut aider l'ordi mais il ya
énormément nul en correspondance mais
sur lesquels qui a quelques parties que
tu réussis à faire tournicoti
tournicoton le chessboxing après c'est
intéressant babaorum aoc c'est
intéressant mais en gros ça sera jamais
un truc majeur en gros tu y as boxing
c'est cool et je vais des pousses bleus
aux gens qui lancent ce truc là bravo à
vous bravo à vous c'est sympa et tout
franchement c'est un kiff
mais en gros on va pas on va pas se
cacher la chose c'est juste et pas très
bon boxe était pas très bon aux échecs
tu es un peu bon aux deux mais ça pourra
jamais devenir un truc my major a plus
propre profil avec trophique cellectis
ben là du coup problème pour pour graver
à tort mais à 6
ouais bon après un premier set serré
d'un pro b cette session parce que sur
cavaliers pour wyeth pour s'éviter
intermédiaire suis pas si vous l'aviez
ouais
donc c'est mort c'est mort d'un match
ait boxing ça pourra jamais remplacer
les échecs à proprement dire allez on va
regarder c'est un kiff m
elle fait mal on va se regarder la
partie depuis le début' est-ce qu'on va
réussir à sauver la partie des bus ou
pas alors je pense sur ses 5 avait
plutôt mettre le foin ans et 7 ici pour
aider aux 5,4 sert qu'au moment où il
fait des 4 en fait on fout il est pas
mal placé sept pour faire aux 5,4 à
avoir les parties de stein ce que
j'avais commenté
voilà on pourra voir la même position
avec le fond ans et sept en gros et le
fou est beaucoup mieux ans et 7 passes
qui l'aident à taper sur le roi donc ça
sera une bonne chose
donc fois je crois hélas il y avait les
f4 qui est pénible attaque le fou
protège le pion un funk ifm
ouais le fou le fou est mal placé la
cavalière 4 c'est super fort ok j'ai
trois pas mal aussi attaque le fou et
prépare cavaliers un cavalier h5 est
peut-être dû dams et de ici en faut 2
pourquoi pas
ouais bon j'ai pas convaincu de la
manière tous les des blancs je pense
qu'il aurait pu faire un peu mieux alors
très dur pour les jeux olympiques et les
échecs et maintenant peut-être du tour d
un tour des quatre tours d1 et ta meuf 3
4 pour les blancs pour essayer de jouer
quand même tirer profit de ce fou et de
cette dame qui peuvent jouer la thur un
coup comme d'hab et phrase peut être
intéressant pour jaillir en f5 et jouir
d'une belle case et sur internet 3g 6 tu
peux te dire oui mais maintenant mon fou
et heureux f4 pas idiot non plus mais
attention ne pas se faire à rire et le
pion parce que là tu vois tu prends un
risque quand même sur un petit dame g4
je t'échange les dames commencer par
parler poliment et où dame madame g6
pourquoi pas il va falloir faire gaffe
avec les blancs de pouvoir faire re 4 ça
va être primordiale et maintenant dame
g4s à peu ça joue vraiment s'il a le
temps de faire le 4 ça peut aller là
mais là il ya peut-être fou prend je
sais pas je trouve qu'avec les blancs il
a joué bizarre aussi
donc j'ai 4 et sur quatre fautes amusé 4
sûrement j'ai pas les blancs se sont mal
débrouillé disons que tu es là bon déjà
j'ai pas aimé qualifié 3 pourquoi pas
mais là pourquoi pas faire juste dames
c'est de ce fou g4 il fait peur aux
mouches
tu t'étais quand même bien tu vis bien
et peut-être tu va préparer du f4
d'ailleurs dans ces cas là où du h3 bon
f4 h3 peut-être mais il a échangé le fou
il n'a pas voulu jouer sur la dame mal
placées après il a fait être 4 f5 et
finalement il va se faire contrer avec
le fou qui varieront f6 il a lui gagné
un tempo sur la tour il va mettre la
tour en 8,2 fois en d4
il s'est complètement désorganisée avec
les blancs après peut-être je dis bien
peut-être qu'il peut encore m haies la
canadienne cissé il ya eu 4 qui reste en
l'air et non mais ça va pas du tout en
fait
marie-mai l'action prend g3 et puis on
prend en fourrant tard un pion - et
c'est la cata il a vraiment mal géré
c'est triste un les mecs
c'est mal géré ça a été mal gérée de la
part de fans qui l'aiment il reste mon
la tour en huit ça va être dur ouais le
fouet f2 ça c'est bien joué
allez faut peut-être tentés ouais
j'avais dit refais tenté peut-être fou
f4 tour b3 et allez quand même chassé
pions skaff ou des deux fleuves de fous
des deux tours 8 au four elle a
peut-être tour de est pénible à [ __ ]
en pions prend fou prend pions pranger
quatre peut-être
faut tenter ça de façon et surtout
reprendre peut-être roigé un tour b3 et
prise j'ai droit à voir
la g4 force et je pense faut tenter ça
et moi j'ai deux sas et à aimer tout un
an
au revoir à ok il veut faire tout re
deux hoquets monte lowey il va récupérer
n'en faut faire rager 3
mais non on repart pas là par angers
troyes et tours troyes tours f3 parce
que la tour le délire du roi qui revient
là il a raté que roy j'ai trois tours f3
et il couvrait les pions il me semble un
après je vous recommande ça mais
maintenant il le fait mais pouvoir la
même position avec un pion à 3 encore
dommage
on va pas les lots qui sont plus blanc
way est un petit problème avec le
détourage des lots effectivement mais ça
vient pas de moi c'est une chaise comme
en fait ce problème avec le chrome
acquis ce que j'aurais fait un chroma
key pour à un truc propres tu vois et du
cou et du coup il ya un peu ce problème
sinon elle changeait tout gris crasse
options des vagues je sais pas il ya 20
ans tout à l'heure non c'est plutôt sur
l'échiquier c'était pas gagné grâce aux
options d ya pas de pions plus le roi
peut pas monter non non c'était 7 nuls
en la finale de pluralité mühlethaler je
pense les moyens de créer un pion
éloigne pas s'éloigner au à tout moment
si jamais annonça devait être nulle
après fallait bien la joue encore avec
les blancs bon là par contre c'est qu'à
part c'est dommage je passe ou qui fait
un peu ce format me discussions sur un
peu discuté de la partie parler avec les
tontons sur le chat un peu ce truc un
peu un peu hybride j'ai envie de dire où
en fait voilà on fait ouais on fait
moitié-moitié on tape la discute moitié
on voit tu regardes les parties l'on se
refait une petite pause sur un mode en
mode en mode full détente quoi tu as et
pas en mode vraiment commentaire c'est
pas vraiment ça c'est vraiment un stream
à la bien tu vois un stream de jeudi
soir tonton club avec la plume quoi tu
as vraiment tranquille aventure et le
petit stream tranquillou sans prétention
sans prétention bien sûr pas de
prétentions sur ce stream c'est du
streaming et quoi tours 4-3 f3 à tours 2
why a peut-être un peu trop de politesse
par contre monsieur pesos à 2 du côté du
chat où il du côté du chat a assez bien
joué ça tours est froid main à aimer
tour qu'à 3 g iii bon il va le faire
tomber un à l'ancienne est ce que je
suis est-ce que je commenterai les
finales du dernier grand prix fille de
jérusalem
allez on va faire un ace que qui pensent
que je commente
le grand prix jérusalem avec m vl et qui
pensent que je ne commande pas question
question pour le chat
je suis un ce repos lgv asylum 2 caps vu
tout ce qu'on a fait jusqu'ici
j'ai envie de te dire est ce que le
grand prix jérusalem sera commentée ou
pas pu temps passe et tu vas le faire il
ya des chances quoi des commentateurs
officiels nv loué en quelques fins
autoproclamé commentateurs officiels et
veulent à temps il va tomber avec les
noirs mais joue plus vite mais joue plus
vite mais tu t'en fous tu lui prend son
truc tu prêt move
non il vas y vas y en a un qui va tomber
va s'y méprend avant ce prêt move non
non ils vont faire nul non ils prennent
move pas ouais il après vous
après moussa sy or il a gagné il a gagné
il a gagné 5 fm au non avec les noirs
tonton tu avais 50 secondes tu avais 50
secondes
oh là là tu avais 50 secondes hall
frérot phyto phyto fort de la key qui a
craqué alors à regarder joseph michel
contre banane verte au nom au nom au nom
il ya un échange ne comptiez pas seuls
et j'espère excès c'est mon nom les amis
prenant les amis au nom au nom au nom
comment il a perdu les amis comment il a
perdu les amis quand t'as quand tu as
une minute contre contre 15 secondes tu
échanges les tours tu joue vite quoi la
pendule c'est une arme c'est une arme la
pendule c'est une arme c'est une arme
la pendule c'est comme une kalach ça
s'utilise quoi tu en as besoin de
pendantes en prenant mes amis j'ai
halluciné les mecs
j'hallucine est là
c'est pas idiot ce truc avec damien qui
avait les machins et où il va falloir
jouer avec du f4 faut faire gaffe de
passe prendre un cavalier des cinq
dimpre en d1 qui est pro f 6 prises tout
reprend mais bon ça a l'air d'aller
non
ah oui mais je le prends comme ça parce
qu'il a le fou en d6 mais j'ai senti
qu'il était mal passé se fout il ya cet
échange là qui est hyper pays dans mail
a fait n'importe quoi la banane verte
c'est plus bananes vertes les amis ses
bananes trop mûres
oh là là et maintenant il ya ces trois
mais là il va il va perdre en fait
partie
enfin il a mûri les amis il va se
prendre un cahier programme six
cavaliers il va se rendre et valoir p4
en fait à méo katie encore que les
problèmes si ce fait cavalier prend mais
à prendre b4 le truc rebouge cavaliers
prend fou prend cavaliers prend il va
devoir prendre du plomb m'en faut
s'accrocher jeu jusqu'à caniveau en
compétition 2300 tu as un niveau pourri
en fait écho plus peut-être quel point
f5 aux cavaliers pros f5 peut-être ça
fait mal parce que puis on prend il ya
cavaliers des six cavaliers fc regarder
comment c'est moche
oh là là il se fait à merise et sur
quels points qu'attaquer projet cet
intermédiaire moche et sur fion prend il
ya cavale des six échecs kovalev cette
fourchette
un niveau m fido et un niveau ecoplus ou
et nick épreuve où ces trois trucs là et
peut-être des trucs mais en tout cas ça
à ça l'est parce qu'il a fait une verte
dames 6 si je vous dois me si si
extraordinaire assez bien joué d'un v6
un ligne les numéros alors dit d'un v6 à
l effort joseph michel et là il va jouer
cavalier des 6 bat il est fort il est
très très fort mais là il va faire
[ __ ] en abscisses et à 9,7
il est bon franchement il était bon chef
michel
franchement il était bon après il s'est
un peu raté banane verte est ce qu'on
veut pas ratifier à l'aréna de bien sûr
bien sûr on peut participer à la reine
je vous met les liens dans les châtains
ça le lien va arriver un il a bien joué
ouais je suis un gem lidl ouais ouais
c'est ça mon chat un chien changer de
marque eco plus quoi donc maître fide
pas même par en plus donc là on a une
anglaise
bonsoir baby luxe à plus carlo
normal à une grosse une grosse
domination dans le tournoi de joseph
michel qui à 9 sur 9
je viens quoi j'ai troqué ses six rock
mais là est-ce que c'est pas les
positions tu peux jouer avec 4 avec les
blancs c'est ça fait genre comme dans
l'est pour faire simple comme dans les
pme iv et que tu caches un peu le fou je
vous passe les anglaises là donc je peux
pas m'exprimer sur la question quoi ce
calcalist c3 qui n'est pas développé
donc qu'est ce que tu peux jouer avec
eux 4 m pour gagner un tempo mettra près
de cavaillon c3 au cas où jouer cinq
plus tard
salut rouh 123 et salut eric besson
nakamura est là dessus tu es tu peux
prendre et développé après cavaliers et
cavaliers ces trois genres prend on y
prend d un tueur prend il prend avec le
foutu fait caillasser 3 mais je sais pas
vraiment ce que ça va tu as c'est pas
genre de positions que je joue
normalement
donc je suis pas un spécialiste du truc
quoi je suis pas un spécialiste du truc
en français 5 après je patate il écoute
un peu l'un le stream va falloir que je
fasse gaffe
j'arrivais changer en france et 5 tu
vois j'ai envie de dire ce que tu peux
jouer genre avec sur 1,3 yoff r15 tu
fais kaïs étroiture à troyes b 4 ou b2
les deux fous des deux côtés les frères
bogdanoff tu as les deux frères
bogdanoff j'ai envie de dire le big bang
n'est plus la même
mais est ce que c'est vraiment bon en
fait tu vas pas j'en sais rien j'en sais
rien puisque ce type n'est pas un gérard
depardieu
j'ai pas trop les mecs j'ai du mal à
m'exprimer sur la question d'un fillon
tu dis peut-être pas assez souvent mais
merci pour ce pour tout ce que tu fais
merci howlin'wolf un nom ne dit pas
assez souvent un an mais vraiment en
plus un on ne dit pas si souvent que ça
en fait on me le dit n'est pas à pas si
souvent
toi tu le dis bravo allez bon donc quel
dessein qui a peut-être venir avec du
four b2 et tu arrives à taper taper les
pions ou 5 du coût par minute ce qui a
fait copier un copier-coller bon là tu
dois prendre les feras tu es fort c'est
ce qu'il fallait vraiment provoquer ça
je suis pas sûr
et là du coup peut-être surtout bedoya
peut-être réussissent donc foudroie
aurait mieux placé non mais je pense
qu'ils jouent par l'image une belle
partie et carpates qu'elle et ses 4 bien
joué la question c'est est ce que fout
d'eux un coup j'en reprends tout reprend
qu'il prend à troyes et tours 17 à 31 je
suis sceptique
allez-vous prendre peut-être à 7 mai
cavaliers c6 ou c5 v6 il va être obligé
de repartir en hausse 3 et peut-être les
noires s'activent je sais pas
tiens ce que tu es ce genre d'arrivée ça
fait fayot d'en remettre une couche ray
mais qu'elle sait si c'était peut-être
pas mal c'est moi le jeune avec le pull
converse rouges à la soirée loïc en fait
j'ai vu tellement durant la soirée que
que j'ai la tête remplie de visages de
personnages en fait de personnes mais du
coup jean rivière de personnages comme
celui tellement qu'en fait c'est c'est
fou en fait j'ai du mal à me rappeler
des visages de tout le monde mais je
reviendrai on refera une soirée en avril
normalement tu pourra revenir enfin
j'espère que tu étais heureux et que tu
reviendras m'apprécient c'était une
vraie soirée ne revient pas te faire
chier avec nouvelle envie de te dire
mais ouais j'espère que j'espère que mr
monsieur p soit viendra la prochaine
fois je pourrais pas fait qu'est points
à 3 et je sais pas je me sens que les
joueurs ont un peu de mal apposition un
peu compliquée mais l'a peut-être même
au-delà de à prendre et il a l'idée de
faire à 5,6 phase 1 qui les rois du
pétrole
moi je n'ai peut-être pas la soirée mais
on est si jamais on s'est croisé dans la
rue je suis brin la prochaine fois quand
est on va sûrement faire ça en avril
monsieur p soit prochaine fois il n'y a
rien de rien de sûr y'a rien de confirmé
qu'il n'y a pas de jeu lâche pas d'infos
c'est juste une idée à ils menacent un
piège
sagem sa salle j'aime ça j'aime cet
esprit de menacer cavaliers deux échecs
on va voir ouais faut f1 mais bon après
ça le problème c'est qu'elle est
peut-être et b3 a tenté de voir
normalement il n'ya rien nulle part
pêcher en eaux troubles mais mon tour c3
et machins et non il va pas il va pas y
arriver malheureusement salut à vincent
lechat tri bon soir c'est un flou
merci à mika était son premier
commentaire youtube de tous les temps
merci tonton à l'option du manager est
en aimant la le temps joue pas un c'est
vraiment les blancs qui sont gagnants il
va envoyer deux pions b mais la paire de
fouras par les souffrances et 4 mais bon
est-ce que c'était si mal je pense que
ça gagnerait fait juste b6 bessette
bêtement et cavaliers a même pas trop de
perdre et de l'afrique et des 3 b b si
ce qui est français 5 comprend les pions
vont aller à dame ça j'en suis convaincu
parce que tu menaces et 6 et 7 et tu vas
pas pouvoir arrêter ça et surtout tour
ici pour empêcher ces six ans va faire
food et 5b 7 6 6 et 7
quoique tu es juste à temps avec le roi
peut-être tu peux arrêter ça comme ça
mais pas avec tour des deux tours c'est
daubagna juste bessette cas la question
c'est ce que cavaler détroit pouvait
sauver le truc des six cas et c5 bc cinq
courses évite ces ordis et l'ordif fo
bay 5-1 avec l'idée sur wife ci de faire
ces six tours prend b 6 et 7
ok trouvable et il n'y a plus de coup de
temps pour stopper
voilà c'est gagne alors avoir un autre
joueur mais on va voir
glonnières 72 contre de foule ce fol
plus tôt ouais non ok ça a été un genre
de système de londres après mais qui a
transposé dans une pire qu hélas les
blancs fait l'erreur typique de se
laisser attaquer des quatre mais il y
aura foule prend h5 donc ça va aller
pour les noirs en fait ouais il n'a fait
cavaler h5 c'était un peu bizarre comme
vous normalement jeu plutôt des trucs
avec fous j'ai quatre ici pour s'en
prendre aux cavaliers s'en prendre au
centre cavaliers h 50 le truc c'est que
lecavalier se retrouve sur une mauvaise
case et il se retrouve en danger mais
c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas joué dame prend
1,5 à cause de cavaliers français de il
a fait tousser un tour c15 j'aurais
jamais imaginé
si j'avais voulu faire tour c'est un cas
ce que vous auriez tout est ici ben moi
j'ai voulu défendre mon petit on est pas
reprendre h5 j'aurais fait cavalier des
l'idée c'est que tu réussisses déjà sa
bouche le fouet et qui pourra plus
attaqué puis de toute façon le pion va
être moche et sinon je laisse quand même
cavalier prend 2,7 et je vais peut-être
jouer ses trois haies dames 3 h 5 tu
vois je veux pas perdre de temps pour
moi tour c'est 1,5 ou vide et après il a
quand même fait 6 2 par lui-même ce qui
est très étrange mais tu vois pour moi
tour c'est 1,5 ou vide ça j'ai pas envie
de faire un coup comme tour c1 comme là
j'ai pas envie de faire foi fils le
fouet ce qui est est ce que les mais
qu'est ce que ce fou et fort en g7 est
ce que ce fou est un athlète non tu veux
faire cavaler des cinq cas relief 4k
réussissent carrier g 6e rentrée dans
les trous je vois un trou j'y rentre
faut à 6 tours g8 tour ici palmarès on
va faire pour emprise tour jécistes dame
g8 d'alger cette tour g8 et on va
complètement replacer les noirs dans la
partie vous voyez ce que je veux dire où
c'est un peu dur là pour vous est ce que
ça picote là dans le chat est ce que ça
picote les mecs dans le chat ou pas ou
est-ce que ça gratouille
bien sûr ça qu'on veut je vois un trou
j'y rentre le foin le fond angers 7
c'est un athlète il tape sur et fils ben
je comprends pas les mecs
depuis le temps qu'on parle ensemble les
mecs
ça va pas du tout elle peut même faire
dame g6 dame prend et puis on prend
effet tour g6 et il va qui va se placer
colonnes colonne j'aime et c'est dommage
c'est dommage
est-ce qu'on a des secondes de nouveaux
followers par le tableau de bord vous
êtes nouveau n'hésitez pas à paulo qui
tourna comme vous disais un sens sans
prétention 100 plus grandes prétentions
qu'il essayait de passer un bon moment
ensemble
après m'en allais l'histoire c'est
quelqu'un peu de temps tout le monde
peut devenir un athlète
ouais c'est dommage c'est dommage
c'est dommage c'est moi je suis allé
faire flasher 6
franchement c'est dommage
bon là on va je vais rien dire je vais
je vais jouer rien dire j'ai envie de
dire un truc mais j'ai pas envie de
spoil
je pensais qu'il allait faire pions pro
f5 pour attaquer le cavalier là bas
puisque l'arrivée à arcalis et ici c'est
tour des quatre c'est un coup assez vite
quand même comment s'appelle jouera sur
une chaise car je ne remettrai je vous
remettre l'union
mike le club a le club chasse comme
désolé j'ai un petit coup de pouce des
semences maïs j'ai toujours un petit
coup de fatigue après une heure en fait
l'impression que une heure de suivre vos
parties les commenter et de regarder
c'est le c'est vraiment le temps de
concentration en fait après après rennes
en une heure pour moi ses rangs le tap
les ministres à 90 minutes sans laisser
plus de temps mais aurait une heure pour
moi c'est vraiment le temps le temps
idéal derrière pas un problème avec dame
est là pour moi ça sent le damel 6 et
tourissima peut-être qui a eu 5 kg 6
jeux pas trop comment il s'est fait
attaquer le roi comme ça
oui peut encore tenir et cavaliers e5
est non mais ça oh la la la la
mais si c'était bien joué dnp si ça
tenait aussi oh lalala lalala non mais
t'as pas le droit mais t'as pas le droit
mais t'as pas le droit mais déjà ta me
cissé c'est un bandit c'est un bandit de
faire dame au 6 mai pourquoi tu non mais
non non non non d'après eux aussi c'est
une dame en un an les amis au nom vaut
mieux vaut mieux voir ça que d'être
aveugle mais quand même aux non les mecs
non mais t'as pas le droit t'as pas le
droit t'as pas le droit t'as pas le
droit mais si bordeaux avait le droit
mais non hélas il ya damage 6 et et tu
vas tu n'en es tu vas pas te faire mater
vraiment mais t'as pas le droit mais
t'as pas le droit mais dans quel monde
tu fais ça dans quel monde déjà celui
qui donne la dalle je me dis n'a pas le
droit mais celui qui la prend pas les
amis celui qui la prend pas alors là
c'est la cata les amis au nom
pas juste pas le droit de jouer comme ça
ah ouais non c'est pas du mv est là les
amis ancien veille il joue comme ça je
vais je vais faire une crise cardiaque
un jeu passe pas le grand prix jérusalem
un des appareils commandés dans le toit
après faut que tu clique sur le lien en
fait du tournoi mais faut bien que tu
rejoigne le club comme il faut et après
faut que tu clique sur le lien du
tournoi ils m'ont fait bégayer
et du coup qui va gagner cette partie je
pense les blancs quand même où les
malins oh là là là là haut il amusé à il
a vu alors à temps est-ce que tu mates
avec les blancs ou pas ici dame g7
s'efforcer cavaliers fc 3 g 8 cavaliers
h 6 3 je suis d'amd 8 aviez vous l'avez
vu sur la ou pas vous l'avez ce match ou
pas est ce que l'élite à ce matou pas
non l'élite ne l'a pas vous l'aviez vous
la combine ou pas est-ce que vous
l'aviez belge ans qu'il avait dans le
chat quand même joli ou paca relief 7
je joue sur le clouage cavaliers h6 je
replace montcaret pour te contrôler la
case et d'amd which de maths
pas si vite mais vouloir y ait eu ou pas
bon là ça va être chaud parce que
glonnières il l'a pas personne ne l'a
après petit tête à prix et shadow stream
il a shadow stream ans il a shadow
stream glonnières ou pas l'évêque
français d'achats de strihou l'apache
ados stream ballerines à gagner allez
bien joué allez on va voir recoler une
chaise contre alex versons safra qui
sache à dos crime 100%
ouais ça n'a trahi et la housse trimag
sais pas comment appeler çà ou là on
fait ce qui fût la petite bande lacarrau
cannes c'est sûr qu'eva lieu de camaïeu
de f3 jamais vu personne joue comme ça
non ça va s'appeler stream a qui
regardaient le stream il regardait le
strip les mecs je pense stream sniper
ait eu assez encore faut être précis les
matins il ya tout un vocabulaire là je
suis pas au niveau
donc après on a nos propres termes en
notre propre au gabut l'air avait envie
de te dire on vit on vit dans notre
monde aussi quoi au bout d'un moment ça
peut arriver c'est pour ça j'en sais
rien moi je sais pas je m'en remets à
l'élite
je sais pas moi à quel point il regarder
où il regardait pas j'ai pas c'est très
très difficile à dire les dames d ici
s'est il va faire jamais en fait j'aime
pas trop ce qu'a fait les blancs avec
l'option avec 3 on sait pas trop ce
qu'il vient faire fait genre cistude
développe foot c'est tout tu peux jouer
avec g6 ou g7 aussi avoir bénéficié non
il a le bénéfice du doute
franchement ils ont quand même mal joué
est-ce que mv à la défense pour le toit
des candidats web est complètement ses
qualités qui le soupçonneraient well
pepy disent tout à fait un répit ce
quelqu'un mais je me rappelle avec qui
je le rappelle et puis je lui dis
bonjour au début ça fait partie des gens
dont je me rappelle je sais je sais à
quoi ressemblait le pays disent épuisés
grands pas aussi grand que l'autre
tchèque mais il est assez grande quand
même tu es partie des gens que j'ai vus
1 dans les premiers
n24 scène c'est quand elle a un truc
marrant c'est fou ces quatre faut cette
fois f4 peut-être avec l'idée sur dames
1re cat france et 6 qui ont prend dame
sait si ces fourchettes mvl s'est
abaissée lundi à partir de 17 heures
lundi dans je commente avec femme et
mardis mercredis avec la ddt
voilà j'ai envie de te dire on va élever
le débat on va élever le débat de ouf je
préfère faut être quatre à 15h04 parce
que là il ya dam des quatre échecs qui
me faisait suer mais ça gagne en fait un
média tu menaces dame prend b5 et
surprise prise la plus de clouage les
amis qui avaient lieu quatre sapeurs une
pièce madame b 4 échecs dames prend dès
5h clasico au nom au nom au nom au non
non non non vous voulez vous voulez me
tuer en fait ils valent ils veulent me
faire baisser mon nom d'un b4y avait
encore y avait encore cavaliers c3 ok ça
gagner pas une pièce mais bon quand même
y'avait dame prend fou prend forcé à nom
d'un bekkat ouais y avait pas les
français si ce temps puisque ces échecs
il est à me prend je prends b5 et qu'il
prend des 4
moi
dames c'est cette fougue et 4 faut pas
faire ce qu adam prend des cadres
par exemple plus notre dame prend les
quatre si on prend dame prend bessin
qu'il aura 5 sera attaqué sur mon site
j'ai mis des conseils de livres baby
luxe hors la loi
dans ces parages où en fait est là
maintenant il faut penser 6 et d'un brin
b4 vraiment la cata 1
bref
alex versons qui a raté deux dames b4 et
qui est puni mallet faut se battre
encore c'est dur les échecs 1 et d'un
premier cas torah c'est un ouais c'est
dur les échecs c'est dur c'est à dire on
va pas on va pas leur en vouloir
c'était pas une partie facile face de
fap c'est très tactique le jeu était
ouvert au centre alors avoir un peu des
gens qu'on n'a pas vu là on à thomas b2r
contre un proche peut tu as et j'avance
petit c'est peut-être un golfeur
c'était à une française genre de en tout
cas ça semblait plus un système own du
coup maintenant il ya du jeu sur les
deux ailes
ces parties intéressantes et de joueurs
qui attaquent le roi allégé 5 quand même
là clairement âgées 5 g mais plus tu
veux qu'elle joue pour g4 et ouvrir la
colonne h tours f5 genre sent que c'est
un peu un coup de côté ça crée pas de
menaces les blancs là peuvent peut-être
faire à quatre pour à 5 sur un 4 à 5
baies 5 / c'est une faute parce que
cavalier à 5 qui bloque tout mais je
pense qu'il veut faire tourcoing f3 sip
genre cifacom dams et de il fera tout
premiers froids tourcoing h3g 5
maintenant mais ouais après c'est
peut-être pas idiot de repasser à 35
c'est pas je crois pas 3 l'attaquent
noir en fait ils n'arrivent pas à ouvrir
tours h4 mais il n'arrive pas à ouvrir
avec les blancs à vous commencez par à 5
et sur bab 5 ça c'est un grand classique
et après tout reprend 1 à 5
c'est ce qui fait hélas faut faire a si
souvent pour empêcher à 6 ans fait et
comme ça tu as le plan dam des trois
dames des cinq situe là c'est quoi si ce
montant encore ces quatre comme rupture
mais a si souvent une bonne idée parce
que tu viens bien enfoncer le clou il
fait des 5 alors là ça pour moi c'est
bizarre déjà il s carrier prend 2,5 qui
menacera peut-être g4 d'ailleurs et
pourquoi laisser ce coup là en fait on a
du mal à comprendre
bref des sucs et prend 2,5 à peut-être
g4 il ya peut-être des trucs encore mais
mais bon en gros tu as l'impression
qu'il est du jeu quand même souhaite
même chez cailler prend 1,5 g qu'a t on
admettant qu'ils puissent pas sauver ton
truc même un truc bête comme cavalier
pranger 4 tu as l'impression que ça te
remet un peu en jeu pion gk tour f4 est
ce que tu es pas heureux avec les noirs
d'avoir un peu ouvert et et enverra du
jeu plus tard monter quand même mal mais
mais bon j'ai besoin qu'il fait à six en
plus et maintenant tour f4 il a un peu
joué à l'envers ce qu'ils avaient les
tours sur la colonne h pour jouer g4 et
il a perdu 3 tempo pour pour pour se
prendre f3 quoi et se faire fermer pas
terrible instat à que la côte et noir
jouent la colonne ajout normal mec te
fatigue pas là il s'est compliqué la vie
approche potes il s'est compliquée la
partie sérieux les mecs c'est compliqué
la partie est-ce que je pense que
carmack m vers la science contre carl
scène bah oui en rapide et blitz il a
souvent des bons résultats contre lui
donc oui il a ses chances m aintenant
dame prend b5
il va aller se faire mater à l'ancienne
il a il a trop voulu faire la danseuse
approche pote ilaina pas
est simple c'est ça me fait penser
parfois têtu tu regardes les matchs de
foot ou quoi les mecs qui tricotent il
met des plombes pour faire un truc alors
que je joue simple donne le ballon tu
vois qu'est ce tu fais des passements de
jambes fait la passe tu vois le truc la
balle elle n'est pas à toi tu vas
partage l'avant même dame bessette damas
est kir protège pour envoyer le pion à
ça peut être une idée
bon maintenant partie pour partie tente
d'un même si sein d'un bessette saddam
des 8 3 7 8 bars et et c'est de bouffer
ici je sais pas tu fais quelque chose ça
va pas chez marc mais tu vois au moins
tu tues templeuve à tous quoi battue va
au bout de tes convictions et là c'était
malinkés blanche et peut-être cahier g4
piégea pas rater une fouine cavaliers
prend dame bigmat bon réciter pas à
citer juste tu joues un bon coup de feu
dame prend à 7 tu protèges le pion et tu
prépares tu prépares tout mais il a trop
trop voulu faire son et marc il a fait
son et marc approche potes non vous en
pensez quoi les mecs il a fait son et
marquent pas
kg 4 et dames ces cinq là ça tu échanges
les dames et après à 7 à 8
non je pars à déraper à jeddah mais il a
fait son démarre quand même ces 5
mais bon peut-être l'eau tu as laissé la
tour revenir dans le français 5e tour f
8 tours à huit ans non
maintenant il ya cette es tu reviens au
nom paroisse h1 aller revient un cours
t'as pas le choix la faut que court mais
non mais non mais non mais non mais non
mais non approche pote fallait courir
tu avais pas de choix jim t'es foutu
quand même mais tu courrais voit la
clepsydre ouais c'est ça sort sans
ressort ouais non c'est dommage
franchement c'est dommage
il peut abandonner un c'est mort guidés
j'ai des sujets par l'épée est à 6 sur 6
web en question c'est la dure loi du
tournoi aïe aïe aïe alors on va regarder
le vieux contre v car ton droit un
gambit écossais on a eu droit aux trucs
avec des quatre qui on prend ça et il a
pris qu'une fois en c3 non c'est dur
c'est dur les amis hébergés cardiaque
lui tarde et à ce soir ben écoute là on
est un peu sur la fin en réalité là il
ya un pion plus pour les pour les pour
les noirs joueurs américains on aura
quand même été d'été nombreux pour cette
petite arena du jeudi après c'est vrai
qu'on a un petit peu perdu l'habitude
des arénas du jeudi à cause de bayeux
beaucoup de tournois aussi faut dire
hein je sais pas si vous suivez un
régime je suis un petit peu mais à mes
yeux beaucoup de tournois ouais ce sera
un grand vide à noah fap de fabre est
tout à fait ce pâté ripert on voit bien
c'est pas une grande position mais avec
le fou en b 6
il verra du cavalier 5
je sais que c'est pas forcément volaille
préférer les lives on commente les
parties de la communauté
je le vois lan g46 peut être peignée
l'acda match 4 qui arrive pour faire le
match de greco c'est une bonne tête la
vue d'oeil et ériger 400 mon cou ouais
je fixe pas volaille volaille préféré
quand on regarde avait un truc marrant
c'est que sur carélie g4 f3 au lieu
tient valiev de au delà de carré des f2
qui est d'une qualité de ce qui est
proche de qui est jouable avec l'idée de
faire d'un match 4 ce pays parce que ray
parce qu'à turin fait jouer ça c'est pas
terrible
si je vous dis progressé 1 écoute je
sais pas à quel point ça vous fait
progresser à des joueurs de votre niveau
mais ça change un petit peu c'est
complémentaire de ce qu'on fait
d'habitude mais je sais que c'est pas
votre votre contenu préféré vous
préférez quand je joue contre vous que
ce soit au coeur je joue ce soit les
arénas où que ce soit les partis
pédagogique et du cou et les gens de
façon qu'ils regardent denis l'ailé
partie pédagogique ni lait ni les arrêts
n'avons pas trop regarder ce contenu là
après je compare pas avec le nombre de
gens qui regardent maintenant et quand
je le fais sur ma chaîne parce que là
comme je disais comme c'est pas un
stream qu'on a l'habitude de faire le
jeudi soir depuis un moment il est -
planifier donc forcément il ya un peu
moins de monde mais mais je remarque que
vous aimez - quand je peux vendre vos
parties je suis pas spécialement étonner
ou quoi mais
meiway
ouais j'aime bien quand je jouais quand
je commente les événements progrès et
les exercices de tonton kef du coup
aller c'est sympa aussi les exercices de
tonton cave c'était sympa il y en a pas
eu beaucoup aussi
mais c'était quelque chose de vraiment
différent alors
par ci un peu spécial les actions
qu'elle s'était bien mais c'était sympa
ça reprendra bien un jour ton mari voire
trois censeurs mais oui clairement je
sais que le format de commenter vos
tournois c'est ce que vous aimez le
moins je le sais par expérience
mais bon après l'arena francophone du
coup il ya pas mal de gens qui aiment
bien la jouer quand même aussi
c'est un contenu un peu faire j'aime
bien le faire bah les parties anciennes
c'est peut-être ce qu'il ya de mieux
pour progresser à l'exerçons parce
qu'elles sont sélectionnées elles sont
vraiment bien
merci habitants que j aime bien les égos
ton conquérait faut arriver à 307 pour
la faire voilà partis talent avec sa
cuisse de l'âne sympa même la partie le
plan de pillsbury et tous et des petits
plants sains pas à mettre en place la
prochaine sera une partie dans les
anciennes parties la prochaine qui
sortira sera une partie de boules binic
et après il y aura une partie d'un mec
qui s'appelle axe qui est pas très connu
mais qui a fait une très belle partie
mais cette partie de talent contre son
entraîneur était et est particulièrement
attrayante j'ai envie de dire c'est
vraiment une belle partie et en réalité
les packs oreilles juste à cause d'un
ordre de coûts mais sacrifice en quoi en
soit il est correct le sacrifice de
dames en soit il est correct
vous savez progressé à 1000 lots bah
écoute fait des tactiques joue
accroche-toi regarder partie pédagogique
et ça devrait aller
ça devrait monter et joue bien entendu
comme de dire monsieur p soit salut
louga 68
il va retourner huit tours g7 g8
ça va aller pour v carton il n'est pas
rare parti à l'aréna battu à mort du
malpas qui est ce que 4 minutes et comme
les parties durent dix minutes tu vas
pouvoir s'inscrire mais pas vraiment
joué 4 je pense qu'après traitement à
faire et à me 5 aidé à me prendre pour
essayer les prendre en g2 à un moment
donné j'ai pas ça me donne envie mais si
c'est un peu tard
salut à kin hawking qui dit gg les mecs
tu as fini combien du cookie knocking tu
niques avait démarré ici sur 6 et puis
finalement tu as complètement craqué
c'est quoi ton pseudo sur sur l'arena du
coup j'ai pas si les classements à jour
d'ailleurs donc j'aime michel joueurs
qu'on ait vu de terre impressionnant
avec un 12 sur 12 pantera fatalis
deuxième album à regarder pour la
deuxième place qui pourrait il faut voir
la partie de hitman alors attendez je
cherchais hitman hitman qui s'ils
gagnent ouais mais il a trois minutes
pour gagner et ils allaient noir devrait
donc il a tout tenté pour jouer vite on
va se refaire la partie vite fait ah oui
la larguer une pièce avec un ruck et il
a complètement craqué sous la pression
et man on avait besoin de gagner vite et
il gagnera pas donc normalement pantera
fatalis qui devrait faire deuxième
génération sous les yeux vous voyez pas
mais oui la 40 points donc c'est joseph
michel qui va faire un inventaire à
fatalis 2 et hitman 3
récupère une tour encore mais il va la
perdre façon il reste 2 50
quoique le joueur avec les blancs ce
qu'a mis en difficulté tout seul
enfilant une tour en 1 annonce assez
mauvais oh la la
la fatigue la c4 c5 c6 ça doit aller
quand même
c'est un petit coup de cavale et f4 pour
couper droit et envoie le pion bon ça
gagne de toute façon assez tour
cavaliers de plus annonce a beaucoup
gaffé du coup le tourin qui va s'arrêter
là le classement qui est figé façon ils
pouvaient parvenir
mais à quand vous jouez les arénas ça
sert à rien de s'entêter là comme le
fait hitman avec les noirs en fait il
pourrait abandonner et essayer d'aller
chercher des petites nul pour refaire
des points bon là ça change rien parce
qu'il va faire troisième mais quand vous
voulez des arénas vraiment le conseil
que je vous donne c'est quand vous êtes
vraiment foutu comme ça il ya un an
vient de perdre une minute 40 de jeu il
aurait pu faire une ou deux nuls en vain
coup il aurait pu enchaîner il aurait pu
marquer deux ou trois points en faisant
des nuls rapide à la fin et
et c'est idiot de vouloir à tout prix la
jouer parce que là au final
hitman il était quand même bien classé
il jouait quand même une place alors il
va attendre la pendule il va la faire
tourner du coup que ça marquera pas les
points mais le problème c'est que lui
non plus ils s'en fichent xav c'est pas
un adversaire direct
donc il a aucun intérêt à ce qu'il fait
il fait juste son nez le temps pour rien
ouais et dont il a le mauvais esprit ça
ça on aime bien ici est le mauvais
esprit dit man c'est beaucoup quoi mais
là en fait c'est le mauvais esprit lui
coûte qu'à lui va il perdra pas il va
finir par exact qu'ils abandonnent un
messager jamais vu encore non mais ça
c'est du jamais vu
non mais ça c'est n'importe quoi c'est
les blancs qui ont abandonné dans mais
jamais vu ça ils abandonner pour se
[ __ ] de sa gueule en fait ça j'ai
jamais vu encore ça ça m'était jamais
arrivé de ma vie en fait ça j'ai là si
vous voulez là c'est un mec il est au
dessus de faire mais ça c'est un cri
offre incroyable il a abandonné quoi il
a il a même pas il a même pas accepter
la nul il s'est dit je me fous ta gueule
j'abandonne est maintenant aussi tu m'as
il va chercher là nul il aurait fini il
aurait fini devant pas de pantera
fatalis mai mais là c'est beau ce qu'il
a fait c'est beau ce qu'il a fait
exams il s'est foutu de sa gueule quoi
c'est extraordinaire franchement il
s'est foutu de sa gueule abandonné dans
cette position fayard il a examiné placé
au dessus de toute la commune est ce
qu'il est dans le chatt xav 12 il sait
là là là il a en gros il lui a craché
dessus quoi ça c'est assez formidable
la belgique au dessus de la france bat
palmarès non non pas au dessus palmarès
de la belgique j'avais une meilleure
position quoi il a dû se dire je suis un
remake de la coupe du monde les mecs
savent qui a fait un remake de la coupe
du monde
palmarès on joue et on veut les
meilleurs échec du tournoi le diamant
pour examen non non non non pas de
diamant pour xav
non maintenant la truie la faillite
riquet tournoi xav salua approche petit
merci tonton pour la partie commenté de
tout à l'heure
même s'il était en dessous de tout comme
neymar aime et vous vous approchez
d'esprit mais je sais pas si les
prophètes de l'esprit et j'en sais rien
les mecs sains il va falloir qu'on fasse
un straw poll pour savoir on se fera un
squale peut-être demain ces personnes
peut lancer je sais pas à quel point il
est au dessus de tout avec cet abandon
intempestifs
j'en sais rien j'arrive pas à me décider
est-il président où est il est-il coeur
de lion quoi on ne sait pas se pose au
niveau de vlad xav laden en vous avez
qui fait mais ce qu'il est dans le chat
se désavoue pas d'arrêt ce qui regarde
les scream quoi peut-être il a aucun
rapport c'est que l'action soit non
habilitées c'est peut-être moins ici si
vous avez été au dessus de tout mais
j'en sais rien et put alors ma façon va
pas faire long feu au mans va pas on va
pas pourrir le la redif la redif youtube
du goût qui est directement en live mais
est face on voit que vous sentez qu'il
est au dessus de tout mais il a
abandonné cette position c'est
incroyable voilà le panache hilal
panache non c'est vrai c'est beau c'est
un bel abandon
je termine 18e cristal je tiens c'est
peut-être cristal puisque cristal funky
fm
mais bravo à toi papa chez nous qui a
fait quatre sur dix il polit tripoli on
l'a pas vu voyage du moulin il ya eu du
monde 80 personnes
la main bisri m'est arrivé deuxième
représenté par pantera fataliste on l'a
vu tout à l'heure son deuxième place de
pantera qui a bien représenté la main et
joseph michel qui était impressionnant
qui a fait un petit 12 sur 12 tranquille
méthane qui a pas pu remonter avec 45
minutes de retard il a fait un beau
tournoi il finit avec 27 points
action qui s'allument 6 5 sur 14
ouais mais c'est l'objectif de s'amuser
si tu t'amuses et a gagné en fait un
s'écrie oh le temps as en toi c'était
écrit
pour ceux qui jouent et c'est écrit en
haut à droite dans la dans la feuille
tournoi
gageons que des 2000 plus ouais c'est ça
russie 1 c'est ça mon toujours ce les
mecs on se retrouve demain à partir de
21h pour l'aréna j'ai envie de dire la
vraie et lundi à partir de 17 heures sur
cette même chaîne pour le clasico magnus
contre maxime je vous souhaite à tous
une excellente soirée bon appétit à ceux
qui n'ont pas encore mangé bon courage à
ceux qui doivent coucher des enfants et
je vous dis à demain quoi
préparez vous ciao bonne soirée à tous